is there advice you can give about you
mentioned israel-palestine the Middle
East
taking on a few conversations on that
topic is there hope for that part of the
world and from that hope is there some
advice you could lend yeah I think I
think I think there's hope there's
then I got friends on both sides
and
um also
when I got my after I left the FBI
um most people listen to this probably
not going to remember who Rodney
Dangerfield was oh come on but he's a
community still doesn't get any respect
yeah yeah yeah and and uh New Yorker is
he a New Yorker I think he was a New
York I like Jersey or something yeah
yeah and um he did a movie a long time
ago called back to school he went back
to school he's an old guy back to school
so I went back to school after I left
the FBI I did get
um a masters at Harvard Kennedy
and that's where you know I'm running
across people on both sides of that
and when they could talk
they said let's start from the promise
that we both sides want a better life
for our kids
which is this version
that I was telling you um earlier from
Tom Girardi let's pick a point in the
future yeah that we're both happy with
and he found that they could talk
you know we all right so it might not be
better for us how do we make it better
for our kids
and that that's where the the Hope
derives from because I think both sides
ultimately want it to be better for
their kids which is why
they still engage in interactions and
which is why I think the leadership
regardless of how
compromised they might be on either side
they're a few straight players in the
game in the Middle East
or anywhere for that matter
um
but they want a better future for their
kids you get people to agree that you
want a better future for your kids now
you start talking about well how do we
work our way back from that
and then all right so we got a mutual
point in the future the
israeli-palestinian negotiations
are also uh for me interesting because
you mentioned Clubhouse about almost two
years ago now
um when Israeli Israel was shelling Gaza
they hit the UPI office
you know they were hitting they they got
fed up with the rocket attacks from
Hamas and of course Hamas is putting
rockets in the UPI office or the AP
office whichever press office it was
there how's that office going to be
there otherwise Hamas is running a show
you know you're not going to run that
office unless they let you unless you
let them store weapons there that's just
part of the game
and and where are they gonna are they
gonna storm in specially designated
ammunition dumps no they're going to put
them in schools they're going to put
them in hospitals they're going to put
them in all places that when Israel hits
them they're going to look really bad
so after a while Israel gets fed up they
start shelling Gaza and they're hitting
these places
a friend of mine Nicole met him
is um hosting rooms on clubhouse and she
says you got to come on the vitriol is
killing me these are all turned into
screaming matches nobody's talking to
anybody
I said all right cool we'll go on we'll
we'll do it and and watch we won't have
a single argument
we'll invite people on from both sides
the only there was one rule
before you started to describe what you
thought of the other side
you had to say before I disagree with
you here's what I think your position is
and you got to continue to stay at the
other side's position until they agree
that you've gotten it
now what happened
no agreement and no arguments
that was what we were really going for
we wanted to show that people
on both sides in one of their emotional
time frames if your only requirement was
you had to State the other side's
position first
nobody got out of control
did it work
that's exactly what happened not one we
wanted to show people that you can have
conversations that do not devolve
into screaming matches with vitriol
talking about how you're dedicated to
the destruction of the other side just
first
see if you can outline where they're
coming from that's really impressive
because I've just having seen on
clubhouse people
which part of the reason I liked
Clubhouse you get to hear voices from
all sides they were emotionally intense
right
it was uh I mean I was I'm sweating just
in the build up of your story here I
thought it's gonna go could go to hell
but you're saying it kind of worked now
to one person lost control of the of the
two sides the people that were speaking
on behalf of the Israelis were a little
better yeah at articulating uh
supportive positions for the
Palestinians
most of the people who want to speak up
on behalf of the Palestinians they just
they they'd want to start in like you're
doing this and I'd say no no no you can
go there just not yet before you go that
you say that all you want
before you go there
you've got to try to articulate to them
where they're coming from they got to
tell you got it right and what would
consistently happen
is there's a leveling out of a person to
try to see the other side's perspective
and articulate it it's enormously
beneficial to the person who's trying to
do it which was really the point that we
were trying to make it's a really
interesting exercise I mean that that by
way of advice so if it works at
Clubhouse for people who don't know
that's a it's like a voice app where you
can be anonymous that's really regular
people but regular people who can also
be anonymous it's just it could be chaos
if it works there that's really
interesting for uh when you sit down for
a conversation across the table from
somebody
don't have them even steal me on the
other side have them just state
the other side just just
you're explaining your understanding of
it yeah that's it and every now and then
I would jump in
like you know and there's somebody
supporting Israel you know whoever the
heck they were
and they they say a couple things
and the Palestinian guy would be like
our gal or supportive of them would say
you know you missed some stuff and I'd
say let me jump in
first of all I know what the Knack by is
the catastrophe that's the day Israel
was born you you know for the rest of
the world's birth of Israel for you to
nakba I said you've got members of your
family
that is still walking around carrying
keys to the front door of the house they
abandoned
and they'd be like yeah
and I'd say you feel bad that in point
of fact that in World War II
the world stood back and watched
while the Nazis threw the Jews off a
building
the only problem was they landed on you
and they'd be like yeah
that's where they're coming from
so articulating you know deeply what the
other side feels is transformative for
both people involved in a process